it was a fitting tribute for an historic
first
lady Rosland Carter's tribute service in
Atlanta was attended by President Joe
Biden and first lady Jill Biden former
President Bill Clinton and all of the
living former first
ladies Jimmy Carter the 99-year-old
former president was there to honor his
wife of 77 years it was a rare public
appearance for the longest Liv living
president in US history he entered
Hospice Care at his home in Plains
Georgia in February the former president
did not speak but their daughter Amy
read from a letter he had written to Mrs
Carter 75 years ago while I'm away I try
to convince myself that you really are
not could not be as sweet and beautiful
as I
remember but when I see you I fall in
love with you all over again during her
tenure Mrs Carter was considered the
most politically active first lady since
Elanor Roosevelt she worked by her
husband's side in the white house as a
supporting partner attended cabinet
meetings and represented the US abroad
she vigorously pursued her own agenda
particularly in improving the lives of
the mentally ill what we witnessed was a
first lady who saw her role as going
well beyond the essential warm and
welcoming host to being a close and
trusted yes advisor in essence an
extension of the president himself once
the couple left Washington in 1980 she
devoted herself to humanitarian causes
along with the former president starting
an Institute for caregivers traveling to
impoverished countries promoting Habitat
for Humanity and a host of other causes
she had met kings and queens presidents
others in
Authority power powerful corporate
leaders and
celebrities she said the people that she
M felt the most comfortable
with and the people she enjoyed being
with the most were those that lived in
absolute abject poverty Mrs Carter will
be laid to rest on Wednesday beneath a
willow tree at the family home in Plains
Rob Reynolds Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer